thousands of demonstrators are expected
to march in cities throughout the nation
today in support of abortion rights the
rallies are part of a nationwide
campaign in response to a leaked
majority draft opinion by the supreme
court that could overturn roe v wade
even though the draft does not represent
the final position of any member of the
court it has raised concerns that the
court could rule as soon as next month
when it decides on a controversial
abortion law in mississippi christina
rafini is on capitol hill with the
latest on this christina good morning
good morning jeff the organizers of the
bands off our body rally here in dc
today say they're expecting as many as
17 000 people including members of
congress like elizabeth warren the plan
is to march all the way from the
washington monument up here to the
supreme court to protest that possible
overturn of roe v wade
hands off women's reproductive health
care house democrats gathered on the
steps of the u.s capitol friday in a
show of support for abortion rights they
won't stop until a national nationwide
abortion ban is enacted on wednesday a
bill to codify row into law failed to
pass the senate the motion is not agreed
to even with vice president kamala
harris presiding senate democrats fell
short of the 60 votes needed to pass
federal abortion rights protections the
senate failed to stand in defense of a
woman's right to make decisions about
her own body west virginia senator joe
manchin voted with republicans to block
the bill saying it went too far
it is not roe v wade codification it's
an expansion on cbs mornings friday
senate republican minority whip john
thune said the issue should be decided
by the states this is a decision that's
been made by nine unelected judges and
it's now going to go back to the people
and their elected representatives but
senate majority leader chuck schumer
says democrats will continue to focus on
this issue between now and the november
midterms elect more maga republicans if
you want to see a nationwide ban on
abortion
if you want to see doctors and women
arrested
if you want to see no exceptions for
rape or
incest and conservative justice clarence
thomas who's come under fire for his
wife's political activism said that
leaked draft opinion has fundamentally
changed the court adding you begin to
look over your shoulder it's kind of
like an infidelity that you can explain
but you can undo it dana
certainly have not heard the last of
this right now christina thank you very
much